[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEREMY WALKER: Hi.
Welcome to YouTube live.
I'm sorry for the delay.
We had some technical
difficulties with the HDMI
app, but we figured
a way around it.
So hopefully, you guys will
get to see the demo.
But I'm excited today, because
we have Skimble on.
We have Maria and John with me,
and they're going to tell
us a little bit about their
product, and then we're going
to do some demos on the Nexus
10, is that right?
MARIA LY: That's right.
JEREMY WALKER: On an Android
First app from what I
understand?
MARIA LY: It is.
Great.
So let's dive into it,
since we're starting
a little bit late.
Let's start with the
history of Skimble.
Maria, do you want to tell me
a little bit about that?
MARIA LY: Sure.
Thanks for having us.
So first off, we wanted to make
it as easy as possible to
have people get fit and active
wherever they are.
And what's great about the
proliferation of mobile
devices is that people have
their phones with them 24/7.
So we really wanted to unleash
the capabilities of the phone
to help people live
more active.
We started Skimble with our
applications, basically to
help ourselves train for the
sports that we love.
And from that grew now three
different applications that
help people live active.
And the latest one is
Fitness Flow, which
we'll demonstrate today.
JEREMY WALKER: So you guys have
a website, too, so you
have a web app where you can
sign up and do some stuff too.
So you have a web app
and a mobile app.
Do you want to talk about the
differences between the two?
MARIA LY: Sure.
So what we offer is a platform
of applications that are fun
and dynamic.
They all tie together on our
website, and just newly
launched for this year are web
workouts that you can do from
the big screen, your
Mac or PC.
The three different apps that
we have right now are the
Fitness Flow app and Workout
Trainer, as well as a GPS
multisports tracking
application.
So as you track your different
activities, whether it's a
workout or a rock climb or
a yoga session, it all
aggregates into your
profile and you can
access that on the website.
JEREMY WALKER: Cool.
And you can share this all
socially, like what you're
doing, and don't you get ranked
or something by how
many workouts you do?
MARIA LY: Absolutely.
So as you complete workouts, you
gain activity points and
you get to rank on our monthly
leader boards against your
friends, people nearby, and
our global community.
JEREMY WALKER: Cool.
One other interesting thing
I saw on "Tech Crunch," an
article about you guys, is you
had some link with Harvard.
There was something you
were doing with that.
Can you tell me about that?
MARIA LY: Right.
So what we do is we work with
a big network of certified
personal trainers, health
professionals, and that
actually includes the Harvard
Medical School.
So we're partnered with them
to collaborate and create
content for our applications.
And specifically, our Workout
Trainer app has a program
called the Harvard Health Gym
Coach, and you can unlock that
inner app to basically get fit
and get trained with a bunch
of workouts customized
for your busy life.
JEREMY WALKER: Cool.
So I'm excited about this.
It helps you work out,
especially if
you're new to it.
But I'm really excited because
you guys are one of our launch
partners for the YouTube Android
Player API, which if
you guys don't know, it's a
native API that you can use to
allow you to play YouTube
within your app without
leaving and going to
a separate app.
So let's look at the demo
because that always helps me.
I'm more of a visual person.
So let's have a look at the
demo, and then we'll talk
about the technical details.
MARIA LY: Sounds good.
So I'll load this
up over here.
So as you get into the app,
you can just click on the
Quick Start button.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Bottom to Bottom Squats.
These squats start and end
at the bottom position.
Stand with feet shoulder
width apart,
bent knees to 90 degrees.
Stand up and squat down, holding
for a one-second count
each time at the bottom.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
MARIA LY: All right.
Let's say we wanted
to mix it up.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Kimura sit-ups.
Start on your back with
your knees bent and
feet flat on the floor.
Place your hands palm
down by your sides.
Crunch up to 30 degrees with
your left arm straight in
front of you and your right
elbow on the ground.
At the top, twist your torso
to the right and bring your
left arm over to grasp
your right elbow.
Return to the starting position
and then repeat,
alternating sides.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
JEREMY WALKER: So this is
actually grabbing a bunch of
YouTube videos, and putting
them together and then
flipping them out, right?
MARIA LY: Yes.
JOHN TIGHE: Right.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Start laying face down
on the exercise mat--
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
MARIA LY: So as you can see,
we're streaming videos from
YouTube and displaying
it on the big screen.
When we have enough of one
exercise, we can choose a
bunch of other ones.
You can even filter exercises,
so for instance, if I wanted
to just do body weight
exercises that,
say, work my core.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Alternating full side planks.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
MARIA LY: Then it'll load the
exercises that are customized
for that specific body area.
Once I've had enough, I can get
a summary of my workout
and in the History View, I can
always do my workouts again.
So it's kind of like a new
workout every time.
Unlike maybe a traditional
fitness DVD that can get stale
fast, we offer hundreds of
exercise videos which you can
pick and choose from and go at
your own pace to really have a
customized workout experience
every time.
JEREMY WALKER: That's great.
So again, you guys are using
the YouTube Android Player
API, so do you want to tell
us a little bit about the
technical integration?
JOHN TIGHE: Sure.
So the challenge for us in
building this app was that we
really wanted to make something
that we think is
more interactive than the
typical YouTube app.
Because as you can see, we're
playing the videos and we're
looping them, and the sound
isn't actually coming from the
video, it's coming from
a separate source.
So we don't have to repeat the
sound as we repeat the video.
And we really wanted the videos
to be driven by the
user interaction rather
than, say, the
video's entire length.
So that created a number of
different challenges for us.
The YouTube API's been
really simple, very
straightforward to use.
So we just load the video,
and then we take a lot of
advantage of all the different
video callbacks you get.
There's a Video Started
callback, a Playing, a Paused.
And that lets us queue the timer
that records how long
you've been doing things, and
there's an Unended callback
that we can use to start looping
the video again.
And then we monitor
that state.
And as we see the videos
progressing, we play the
different sounds that correspond
to the stage of the
workout you're in.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
Now, what part of the player
API, because we
have different versions.
We have a full one
that will pop up.
Of course, we have an example
of all of this, like a wall
and everything.
We have fragment versions.
Which particular one
did you use?
JOHN TIGHE: This is just the
YouTube Player View.
And then we also take advantage
of the Thumbnail
Views for the List Views you
can see on the side there.
Those are all Thumbnail Views.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
So you have a couple
of them running.
JOHN TIGHE: Yeah.
JEREMY WALKER: So I guess what
I always like to ask is--
something we always ask is what
language did you use, but
obviously you used Java, because
that's all you can use
with the Android Player API.
But did anything surprise you
when you started integrating?
That said, you guys did start
early in the beta period, so
you gave us a lot of feedback,
which is great.
But anything actually even
during that period that
surprised you as you
were going along?
JOHN TIGHE: No.
I mean, just to be honest, to
me, "surprise" is sort of
maybe a bad word when you're
working on a project.
And no.
There were some moderate changes
to the course as you
guys progressed towards the
actual launched version of it,
but no, everything was really
straightforward.
So I thought it worked
very smoothly to be
integrated into the app.
JEREMY WALKER: I guess
I should have said
counterintuitive maybe.
But no?
JOHN TIGHE: Not that
I can think of off
the top of my head.
For the functionality you get,
it's really a pretty limited
set of things you have to pick
up, just a few basic objects.
Play a video, show
a thumbnail.
It's all pretty straightforward.
JEREMY WALKER: Pretty
straightforward.
Great.
That's good to hear.
So we always like to ask, are
there any features that you'd
like to see in the product?
And I know you at least
mentioned one offline, which
you're welcome to
mention again.
You were talking about you're
hoping to eventually release--
because people don't know
this, but this is an
Android First app.
And for you guys to do
everything that you need to
do, you need a pretty low level
of control with the
YouTube Player API, correct?
So I think you were saying
you're looking for an iOS
version of this as well.
JOHN TIGHE: Yeah, we'd love to
see an iOS version of the
Android API, or the YouTube
Android API.
No pressure.
JEREMY WALKER: We've heard that
before, and I always like
to bring it up and at least
hear all the feedback.
But we've definitely heard that,
so we hear the feedback,
and we're looking into
it as much as we can.
MARIA LY: And just to add to
that, I think overall, the
experience working with the
API has been fantastic.
And we really like being able to
stream our exercise videos.
They're HD in quality, so
bandwidth is sort of
a concern for us.
So what I'd love to see would
be an even slicker way to
provide our streaming experience
in areas where the
bandwidth might be a little
lower or you might have some
issues with connectivity.
We also provide an Offline Mode
setting, which provides
all the audio coaching, timing
cues, and motivational
messages sans the
video itself.
So being able to manage the
experience in providing an
optimal experience for areas
or times when you have high
bandwidth, and also lower
and even none.
JEREMY WALKER: OK.
That's a good suggestion.
I'll definitely take that
back to the team.
Well, we usually like to
traditionally open it up, see
if we have any questions.
I'll see if anybody's
asking anything.
So there's a question
about IO.
And obviously, just keep
an eye on our IO site.
If you want to join,
go to that.
There is a bug report.
But of course with YouTube, we
always look at bugs, so you'll
want to go to YouTube.com/dev
and just log your bug there.
We definitely look
at all those.
And if you do have any
questions, you definitely want
to send them to Stack Overflow,
because we actually
keep track of that.
But for bugs, definitely
look at that.
And then there's, of course,
the same question.
We put the same question
as a plug every week.
Is YouTube Developers hiring?
And we are.
Just go to
developers.google.com/jobs,
and just have a look there
if you're interested.
Thanks again for coming.
One more thing I'd like to point
out is you were telling
me, aren't you rated
on the top?
You want to talk about
that, your ratings?
MARIA LY: Sure.
So we launched Fitness Flow in
time for the new year, and
we've already seen it
organically grow to be one of
the top apps in Free and Paid
For Health and Fitness
category on Google Play.
So I think right now on tablet,
we're in the top 10 in
both Free and Paid.
And our other application,
Workout Trainer, is also up
there as well, top 10.
JEREMY WALKER: So if you don't
remember, you'll see it when
you look at the top downloads.
Because actually, that's where I
found it when I was browsing
around before I started
searching for Skimble.
It was pretty cool.
But thanks for coming today,
thanks for talking about the
Player API.
Any other closing words?
JOHN TIGHE: No.
I mean, just thank you for
putting this out there.
I think it makes life a lot
simpler for Android
developers.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
We're happy to help.
And download the app.
It's pretty cool.
I've been playing with it.
You'll get a workout.
MARIA LY: One sit-up
at a time.
JEREMY WALKER: One
sit-up at a time.
All right.
Thank you for coming, and sorry
again for the delay.
MARIA LY: Thanks
for having us.
Bye.